[Applause]
country artists I am I'm gonna get very
no I'm not gonna do that people don't
drink here you're too young ha ha I
can't I gotta be appropriate da I can't
be appropriate but I'm gonna I'm gonna
have a drink I'm gonna have a drink is
it hey I am gonna celebrate for you hun
even I think I am in markets I am so
happy you're the voice crowned there
season 15 champion last night making
coach Kelly Clarkson the winner for the
second year in a row the 16 year old
country country singer I should say who
is now the recipient of $100,000 and a
recording contract is joining us live
right now we're thrilled to welcome
Chappelle Shepard congratulations thank
you I could see the glow I mean that was
an amazing amazing moment I mean how do
you feel how does it feel now has it
sunk in yet that you won the war you're
just still on cloud nine just happened
last night it's crazy Wow and a win for
Team Kelly two years ago and Britain was
there last night too yeah I mean what
think wait till I can be able to share
that moment with brain but of course
you're coach it's awesome because just
seeing Brandon how Kelly is like stuck
behind her throughout her whole like
experience since winning the show it's
really cool knowing that Kelly's there
for me as well I love that and of course
you know obviously winning the show we
just mentioned in addition to a record
contract you get to receive $100,000 all
right no big deal where are we going out
for live job on the show but what do you
plan to spend that money on you know I
really want to buy a car and now that
you're 16
yeah and I'm named after a car my dad we
have a whole bunch of hot rods and I
love cars so I of course want to buy a
car I love that I know winning was
amazing but we're seeing his clip right
now of you performing with Dan and Shay
I mean that was so how cool is that for
you like was it everything you thought
it would be it was amazing dan + Shay
are there they're so nice and they both
can sing
like y'all saw on TV they are amazing
and I just it's just so awesome being
able to spend time with country singers
that love country music just as much as
I do well will you be spending more time
with country singers what is next for
you are you going to make a move down to
Nashville maybe um well I'm gonna go
home and thank everyone for all the
support they've shown me along this
whole crazy journey and then I'm just
gonna be a normal teenager for a little
bit and then I'm gonna start working on
a country album so I'm super excited for
that I want to just tour the world and
show people why I love country music and
go to the Grand Ole Opry if this is
Lawrence melon I love that I do want to
ask you know you are working on a
country album and I'm a big country
music fan and right now in the industry
we're kind of seeing women not being
treated you know as fair right now
especially when it comes to radio play
and in tour opportunities has Kelly
Clarkson or even Blake Shelton given you
advice before you kind of embark in the
industry like that you know Kelly has
always told me to be myself and to just
have fun and show just show the world
who I want to be as an artist and to
just love what I'm doing because not
many people are singing classic country
music anymore exam I want to bring it
back music to my ears right yeah there's
a machine as we saw in that interview
clip right before you walked on she is
so excited that she beat Blake I know
that friendly rivalry is not the same
for you in the contestants you got
really close with some of them I mean
what was this whole experience like for
you getting to know all these amazing
amazing talents it's awesome being able
to spend months in a hotel with people
that you share the same passion with I
was really close with Sara Grace and I'm
really close with everyone so it was
super cool being able to spend all this
time with them and go along the journey
with people backing you that just love
what you're doing and now that the show
is over and kind of everyone you know
goes their separate ways I would imagine
you're gonna still remain close with
Kelly any chance that you guys could
collaborate on something
yeah show together that was so fun after
we got done performing she just we
should do that at a concert together or
on an album
so cool our duet is on iTunes chart
returns oh it's really really cool and
then she open for Bryn recently - at a
small gig I think she did I'm just
saying I feel like you have a lifelong
friend and partner and Kelly yeah she's
like a big sister yeah any other dream
collaborations for this future album
record really well I'd love to collab
with Loretta Lynn um Dolly Parton Carrie
Underwood I have a whole bunch of people
that I look up to see what I love about
her shootin she really wants to bring
that country back like the traditional
countries the Loretta's the dolly I love
it how would you sum up this entire
experience the voice it's surreal and
it's just it's extraordinary because not
many teenagers get to stand on the voice
stage and sing for millions of people on
national television so I'm thankful to
everyone and just this whole experience
I'm just I feel blessed what I was just
said what advice would you give to
someone who maybe is watching who wants
to follow in your footsteps and maybe
audition for the show next season I
would say go for it and don't let
anything stop you because if you love to
sing and you love to perform you should
definitely do it and just follow your
dreams whatever your heart desires you
should go for it
you never know where Italy
congratulations it was really really
nice to meet you Thank You Sheikh outfit
she's got the fringe going on we love it
Congrats and thanks for joining us you
guys the next season of The Voice
actually returns February 25th if you
can believe it this time with John
Legend taking over for Jennifer Hudson
so we can't wait for that
[Music]
[Applause]